if it's really weird like I put her face
on like ET or something then she'll be
like I guess cuz that's I can't really I
can't be the dumbest
man welcome back to careful boys we are
indeed careful boys and we are also
afraid of everything check out the merch
very afraid so oh wow I have a question
for you guys and I I want us to take
this topic very seriously okay is making
deep fakes of our own chicks messed up
or is that completely legitimate I hav't
even thought about that wait we're the
ones making it we oh we making about our
CHS you
just I just have a new idea thanks to
you dude I'll try it out for personal
profit I thought it was personal person
what's your idea what's your idea oh
personal enjoyment so you just want to
see other dudes ramming your girl what
no not for sex but it can be I was
thinking about putting Han on Trump and
make her do Trump speeches oh that's
really good that's really good consider
a I was thinking about having like Nikki
hugging me and telling me I did a good
job and
[Laughter]
stuff but I like the sex idea def work
in a sense I think so is there a website
where I could do going to hug you no no
no so no so Nikki was actually sending
me some AI [__] that she was [__]
with last night and this is where I got
this idea cuz she was sending me like so
she has she has um a story about how um
she got rejected by a cheerleader group
when she was like in high school it's a
real story a real story and she was
basically like if not for that I could
have been like one of those cheer girls
but she's she's like instead I like
withdrew and became like a internet
weirdo because they rejected me and I
was like I'm never going to [__] do
anything social again basically for a
couple years right so then she sent me
these AI pictures randomly last night
after she told me the story at like 2:00
before I got on an airplane 7:00 later
she's like sending me these AI photos of
her as a cheerleader and I was like this
is kind of
tight I'm got into this and it's a above
board cuz that is technically my wife
yeah yeah so what if I but she she aied
herself she aied herself you didn't AI
her I didn't AI her but not yet but now
that I have the little cranking around
here but if you do it are you going to
show her or are you doing it because you
I don't know it just depends on what I
make what do you think you would make
like what are some top options [__] why
her getting [__] by
Godzilla you know are you a big Godzilla
fan love
Godzilla I like how big he
is I love his tail some of those like
AI like like you know how they did the
um if the the like the if friends was
Asian and then they they had an Asian
cast or like if if it was like Samurai
but it was like black samurai and then
they were all like or like rappers that
were samurai or whatever and then I'm
like that's real cool but I kind of
sometimes wish what I would look like I
wonder what I would look like in
different cultures but then later I was
like oh what that that just looks that
just kind of like blackf facing myself
so I'm scared to get can but is AI doing
it but I feel like there's somebody
there's an African Joe out there
somewhere for sure there is was it I
mean are you just going straight to
Africa though I mean you could no I want
to do all kinds that's what I'm saying
that's the one everybody wants to see a
few other cultures Brian's about to do
right now Ryan sitting here hearing
about what you're thinking do a
Shakespeare and Joe what does the
Shakespeare and Joe look like I want to
do
Renae every culture Joe because our fans
sends us a bunch of doppelgangers that
shit's always like hilarious and I'm
like what would that look like yeah dude
Joe is black Godzilla what about black
Godzilla African Godzilla hip hop
Godzilla system just
crashes hip-hop Godzilla Ryan you made
you made smack do some stuff huh you
sick
[__] no but I I think for fun uh I mean
it's fun to do that I haven't sexually
done it yet yet big keyw there there has
to be like there's this like there's
this picture of her holding this little
stuffed animal and I was like oh what
would that look like as a like Never
Ending Story like fantas like fantasy
that's pretty cool that's really good
what app is that mid Journey mid journey
is like the best yeah it's like one of
the best AI what does it do what does
mid Journey do do you have to pay for it
you just l
tell it what you want it to make that's
it saw I saw somebody take their own
picture and then um they were like
working out or something and they took
that picture and they were like put me
in a business outfit like a professional
business outfit and I was like and they
showed it and it looked really [__]
it looked so real you want to do that
business yeah can we do business yeah
yeah I want to look Prof
professional oh did you see the one that
everybody was like uh Organized Crime
Boss look that was really sick yeah
what's with everyone in like School
everyone's been posting the yearbook the
yearbook oh there's a '90s one so Nikki
showed me some yearbook ones too the
'90s think about that I liked it I liked
it quite a bit started beating it
instantly but the thing is we already
have '90s pictures so why are we making
'90s AI pictures because a lot of them
weren't born in the '90s most of them
are in boxes and our parents addicts and
[__] and you get to play the characters
you never were like you could be the Key
Club guy you could be the choir guy
soccer player guy and I do still think
most of the people are posting it
weren't alive in the 9s like this guy
could be the nonsex guy what would that
have been like oh it would be a picture
of me not
impossible wait what's it called because
I looked at Mid Journey but I can't find
it on the app store called mour it's not
on the App Store you got to use it
through Discord is like the main place
there's a lot of fake mid Journeys out
there this like trying do crypto it's
like you have to go on the so road to
download mid Journey it's like it works
through a Discord server yeah it's like
uh it's kind of a pain in the ass to use
but it costs like I think the lowest is
like $90 a a year I believe you know
some crazy [__] huh [__] but really easy
go $90 a year no no no the what the what
he's saying what he's doing is really
easy it's like typing sentences it's
super like kids are doing this [__] you
got to be [__] in some Discord
[__] dark web room no Bart discord's
just a chat place it just looks weird
you know you have one right I know on
the JK Pat and can you quickly make them
like right now yeah would you be able to
do like but but it's like it's all
[__] up cuz it gives you what it does
it gives you variations and then you
tell it what's closer and then it works
off of that and it just keeps like
getting closer can you just like put
like Joe on Bart's body for fun oh
that'd be fun I mean that I think you
could just use a regular app for that
you could just do Photoshop Photoshop
that easily actually yeah easy you could
just use face app for that okay let's
get back to the [__] topic what's the
topic what's the topic it's making deep
fakes of our own chicks messed up or is
that completely legitimate I think it's
all context I think if you make it
because you think it's funny so you can
show your chick I think that's totally
fine okay let's do the inappropriate one
which one is more inappropriate okay
your wife's body with someone else's
face or someone your wife's face on
someone else's body that's well whose
body again if I put her on body that's
funny that's I think L lose to make you
horny that's wrong always to jackma I
think I'll [__] get horned like a
bars body all day it's the same dilemma
is it yeah cuz you the way you're you're
jerking about your wife on someone
else's body yeah that's tough that's
that's aough you're going to get in
trouble is that the crime that's the
that's what you're going down is that
the crime but I think if she caught me
looking at a photo of her on a fat
person's body to jerk off it would be
less offensive if she if she caught me
with her body and someone else's face I
think that that's much more someone else
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what I
mean really though I think
so if if she took a photo of somebody
else and put it on my body and I was
like no I was jerking off to you but it
was clearly somebody else's face I be
like that's someone else's face is weird
someone else's face but if it's me on a
buffer body I I would feel insecure
about myself but I would understand what
if she caught you jerking off to a
picture of her face on her body but it
said
Sarah so it's just a different name a
word a different name that's that's
[__] up that's pretty yeah I don't
know what that's kind of tough you
always impress me with what the [__]
that looks nothing like
me let me see yeah of course it doesn't
that's Bart's like what if you're
jacking off a totally different chick
and then it says Nina on top that looks
like simu and I just took a picture of
him and I said make him look more like a
superhero that looks like simu and Bart
had a baby technically simu is a turn
you a SE that looks like someone I've
seen at like the [__] Asian-American
Film
Festival all right hey this guy's kind
of hot though Joe what's up he looks
like a generic China man if you told me
this guy was like next week's guest I
would believe
you next week's guest and he's like a
fitness instructor he told me that that
was Joe's older brother I'd be like oh
[__] the Jitsu was n I'm the better
looking one you got all the good
jeans all right uh scenario two okay
okay uh your why okay AI Style m [__]
deep fake your wife's face which will be
worse though if she caught you jacking
off to I don't know like H Berry's body
or lizz's body whoa well and Nikki's fa
is on both yeah it's both Nikki's face
but then one is like you know I think
the the lizo one would would require a
conversation yeah that's what I'm saying
yeah like a longer Joe's like no matter
what they've got to have some sort of
African element to it though all right
[__] how about this Adele 20 2010 versus
Adele
now fat but
still I think that the Adele 2010 would
still require some sort of conversation
what about this what about gab c c gab
Cay who's that you guys all know
precious she was in Precious uh never
mind I don't no okay because both are
what's the actual crime because both are
achievable bodies both are achievable
bodies for her but then one will make
her less insecure let's make this let's
make this simpler yes is it messed up to
make deep fixes of your own chick no
because you own her now you pay for it
that's what I think so you can do
whatever the [__] you want with that
copyrighted image you bought the
likeness yeah rights reserved All rights
resered when you're married you're good
bro if you if you publicly share it then
do you owe her the pay-per-view buys I
completely agree with that yeah you need
to share it with consent yeah yeah you
can't do that that's very true yeah
that's true your own personal fun yeah
cuz if you make naughty videos at home
and then you just share her [__] with
other people without her consent that's
not Co yeah that's not cool not cool but
if you're both making money from it and
if it was agreed upon because you guys
were PornHub creators okay how about
this you take 70 % of her face likeness
through AI you attach it to a completely
different body you create an only fans
account and you give her 30% of the
money Sophia varara this time 30% Sophia
vagara sure because pretty good I'm
going to stop saying black people
because you're you're you're painting me
out to be only black people I think it's
pretty inclusive actually sop Sophia
vagaro is part of black though damn it
she's mostly
African significantly African he's
African I think I thought she was she
could have been like like a Caribbean
Latina Caribbean Latina I think the
conversation I would have with Gio would
be it was more so based off of what the
actual deep fake is so like let's say if
I put her in like uh she's like a
basketball coach she'd be like that's so
doable like if you wanted a role play
like that why don't you just talk to
me is that doable really yeah like if
it's like a very doable thing like
she'll be like she was like wait you
have to go through all these things to
like jack off to me as an NBA basketball
yeah where I could just went to like
Salvation Army and bought some clothes
and we just role play like you know what
I mean would she actually do that for
you like if without without laughing and
making a mocker would she wear like the
suit like like a basketball coach would
she'd run up and down a basketball court
with her and you guys fight being mad
like having clipboard be
[__] on the basketball court losing
her voice so she's yelling at you all r
yeah I think all of that would be cool
she keeps making bad calls and you guys
fight and then make out at that moment
but the basketball court if it's really
weird like I put her face on like ET or
something then she'll be like I guess
cuz that's I can't really I can't the
dumbest man in a world where she's uh
role playing as the coach who what's
your role I'm a
player he's a he's a water boy I play
for the Sparks yeah and she keeps
blowing the whistle on them he goes man
what's your [__] problem and then
they fight in the middle of the court
and start making out you're role playing
as a WNBA player I don't know D maybe
you're a bench WNBA player and you got
to get your way back on the start and
we've always had this coach player
tension yeah yeah yeah wow she doesn't
want to give you favoritism that's why
she's putting you on the bench yeah even
though I'm the star player my stats I
need my spot coach you guys are watching
film together and you guys got a the
star NBA WNBA player it's like I want
you to [__] stay after in the locker
room help clean up because you suck and
then you guys are just she's teach you
how to post up oh oh [__] oh and then
the ball the ball rolls away but we're
still in this position oh that's good
she calls you bartha AR you get off me
man the role play's over no then let see
how this is kind of hot yeah what
happens next this is the only time I've
watched WNBA and liked
it Mark can't reach the rim dude GI are
playing the roles he definitely can't
reach the room no dude no [__] way
that's why it's called the room job okay
so now that was innocent enough it's a
basketball coach and all [__] what if
you do some [__] up [__] like some
[__] devil demon [__] what would be
some weird your chick's getting Gio's
head gargoyle's body dude dude Gio
getting [__] by Diablo from Diablo 2
yeah Diablo
2 that would probably be a conversation
she like what the [__] how Drago's menur
body Gio's head or if it's like nad's
body in Gio's
head she probably like Kink sham me you
like that [__] she's yucking your yum
don't yeah don't yuck my yum she's
yucking all your [__] up those are my
yummies damn it would suck to get caught
doing something like that dude getting
caught jerking off it probably be like
really bad huh it's already bad that's
already bad yeah I think just getting
caught jerking off in general is that
would be the conv you know what's funny
do you feel like there women are always
going to be like yo like what do you got
jerk off for like I'm here but then
anytime you ask for it and stuff like
that it's not available the same way
jerking off they fronting bro yeah
they're fronting until they understand
that then they're like which is why
which is why I think in your scenario if
Gio had the option to be like oh you
want me in a [__] referee you like
why wouldn't you I would have done that
I think that's different because she saw
the AI so she saw how [__] serious
like after the fact yeah but if you were
like hey I kind of want you to do this I
don't know if it would immediately be
like yeah let me go do it cuz I'm down
I think you really have to convince them
that you're down just as this convinces
that you're [__] down no I think well
because me and her had hella ecstasy
conversations so we know know each other
now oh wow I mean so we have like more
of the story I need more ecstasy me too
it's fun doing it with your pal it's
like you're hanging out with your
pal I want to do that it's fun doing it
with your coach I mean pal WBA coach
Camp C I mean Gio yeah have you guys
ever has your lady ever like approached
you like in the mood she want to have
sex with you but you're like oh I just
don't want sometimes I've had those days
where I'm about to fall asleep and I'm
like I'll try and then before I stick it
in I'm for real that just happened to me
on Monday if dude if I drift off and
fall asleep I am not in the mood after
it's out doesn't matter yeah it's hard
what's the reaction afterwards what what
is the repercussions do they give you
[__] I just had to do it the next night
and not wear my Bon
shirt oh that's not fair you know that's
pretty
Petty I felt like I used to [__] no
matter what the weather was but then
Hawaii is a different level of hot that
I didn't realize I'd be like this is so
[__] hot our bellies are going to
stick I'm not used to I'm okay with dry
hot but like humid hot I'm just and we
don't have AC so I was like that's a big
Rin check on the sex I need AC and the
cut the [__] cuddling is like this
bro get away from me don't T like I have
no blankets on we're this is the we're
touching pinkies no AC I'll never [__]
again I don't care I'll never have sex
ever no AC is no good yeah the older I
get the more bougie I am yeah but back
in the day though man I could be in a
volcano and I'm like yo I'll [__] 2
minutes in I bust and I'm like
yo
yo and like why am I in a volcano this
is weird 2 minutes to 30 seconds later
though why that could be a 200° sauna
post nut Clarity you're like man we
climbed into a Volcan can't to [__] that
was crazy we're
nuts Anthony what would you have nah
doing you sick [__] hey isn't the time
over I'll probably do like a I don't
know NBA coach that's Ste my idea who
whoa whoa dude don't King Shame me yours
is WNBA don't King Shame me I'm not just
genders you're just copying me like I
feel like you're King shaming me right
now can we please stop so Nina's the
first um woman who makes it to to the
NBA and then you're coaching her is that
it o that's that's dope oh she's a
heckling fan behind me talking [__] on
my coaching patterns oh [__] she's a fan
I see your clipboard the giant the giant
fingers [__] you're at the free throw
line you're at the free throw line she
still keep it on Anthony so that's her
deep F you're going to make she's a fan
holding a big signs up guys time out big
one big one finger that's going to go up
your ass later she got two sodas that
she's sucking on
CU people still do that that's cool and
it says Duff beer on
them that's so innocent do people still
do those the two beers with the straw
yeah
[Music]
sure